thank you guys who have been sending
well wishes while I was in the hospital
I just got home from Friday night
they're a Highland back at home after
spending days in the hospital with
health issues long story short I went in
because I was feeling like I was being
choked from whatever in the house the
Modern Family star says doctors could
not figure out what was wrong with her
they ran multiple tests multiple time
there's nothing physically wrong with me
so she wrote on that video quote no
scientific explanation hmm
Sarah offered up no other news but did
seem excited when her boyfriend Wells
Adams returned likely from shooting
bachelor in paradise in Mexico Sarah
spent years in and out of hospitals any
time I talk to anybody about something
I've been seeing him in a while they're
like oh my god how you feeling they
bring you soup less than a year ago she
revealed she had a second kidney
transplant you know when a family member
gives you a second chance at life and it
fails it almost feels like it's your
fault it's not when a second family
member someone who you're supposed to
look after like a little brother wants
to give you a third chance at life
it's scary earlier this year she seemed
to be on the mend telling me gee I just
came back from Mexico and that was
really really nice um the good thing
about being stable health-wise is in
having an amazing significant other is
that now I'm able to travel more and I
wasn't
for remember the last time I took a
vacation before this year I think I was
24 just turned 28 so I had just been
either working on my health or working
non-stop
so it's really nice to be able to do
something like that now
[Music]